Ginger armor is the daily moisturizing
mineral sunscreen perfect for any skin
type chemical sunscreens can cause
health issues including skin irritation
and stinging eyes but with ginger armors
ingredients from plants and minerals and
it being scent free and rubbing on
invisibly in seconds it's the best get
15 off with code Pacman using the link
below well we're starting with two
stories from Texas today and nothing
really says the Christmas spirit like
Texas sending buses of migrants to
deathly cold temperatures at Kamala
Harris's house and that's exactly what
took place and yet Texas has real
problems to deal with specifically the
fact that they have another Power
emergency yeah this is not a show from
last year Texas having another Power
emergency for more or less the exact
same reasons that they have in the past
we're gonna get to that though let's
start with the migrant Story New York
Times reporting buses of migrants arrive
at Kamala Harris's home on Christmas Eve
about 130 migrants from Texas were
bussed to the vice president's home on
one of the coldest Christmas Eves on
record in the nation's capital this is a
good article by Stephanie Lai that
explains
um what took place over a hundred
migrants arrived near Kamala Harris's
home Saturday evening one of the
chilliest Christmas Eve's on record
volunteers anticipated three buses with
about 130 migrants to arrive in New York
on Christmas Day the buses were rerouted
to the Washington area because of road
closures and frigid conditions migrants
arrived in Washington after a 36-hour
journey
some with little more than a t-shirt or
a light blanket the mutual Aid group
helped coordinate travel and housing for
them provided food coats shoes other
warm articles temperatures plunged below
20 degrees the mutual Aid group said the
buses were set by the Texas division of
Emergency Management following the
directive of Governor Greg Abbott's
office I don't have to tell you whether
he's a democrat or a republican you know
from what he did quote they've been
doing this for a few months now it's all
for the spectacle the cruelty is the
point it's awful to use people in this
manner for political reasons
um we have video and uh as you will see
here
um folks arriving as you see some some
are wearing shorts quite literally
shorts the temperatures got below 20
degrees buses being unloaded and this is
a political stunt it is farcical it is
disgusting it's also dangerous it puts
people in danger because of the
temperatures we have another video here
as well you see the clock 10 p.m there
uh buses arriving people have been
handed blankets at least some of them
have but you do see folks very much
underdressed and it got very very cold
in the Northeast on Christmas Eve the
White House is a sailing Texas governor
Abbott per report from Reuters writing
the White House on Monday accused Texas
governor Greg Abbott of endangering
lives after busloads of migrants from
the Southwest border in Texas were
dropped near vice president Kamala
Harris's home in D.C
the Republican Abbott has not
acknowledged the drop and his office has
not claimed responsibility
um
yeah so what do we say these are people
who are prioritizing their own agendas
over the well-being and safety of others
and it's nothing short of disgusting and
absurd people's lives are being put at
risk people woefully uh unprepared for
the temperatures that slammed the
Northeast over the holiday weekend and
they're being used as political ponds so
number one we should recognize that
these are human beings they are looking
for safety they're looking for a better
life for themselves and their families
they don't come to the United States
willy-nilly remember many of them are
leaving families and the only homes that
they have known to take a risk and to
try to make a living now remember they
are both lazy and taking our jobs so
wait they're lazily taking all of our
jobs by working all of those stories are
completely pathetic and inconsistent we
know know that but these are people who
are making life-altering decisions to
try to better their circumstances and
there are folks like Texas Republicans
more than it's not even willing eager
to exploit them
secondly when Governors do this Abbott
DeSantis Etc not only does it fly in the
face of basic human compassion and
decency it often actually is misstating
or misunderstanding the legal status of
many of these folks I don't yet know the
legal status of these 130 individuals
oftentimes the term migrant is used and
then it's often replaced with illegal
immigrant but in a prior busing stunt
where migrants were bussed to the north
they were folks who were actually that
they they requested Asylum and their
cases were being processed and they were
not actually here what we would Define
as illegally per the law per Asylum law
and so understand that very often it's
not even accurately making the very
deranged and inhuman point that they are
trying to make last thing
Americans are actually in agreement on
many aspects of the immigration debate
particularly DACA few were six when you
were brought here by your undocumented
immigrant parents and from age six to
twenty you grew up in the United States
went to school in the United States Etc
it would be insanely cruel and illogical
to send that individual who was six when
they came here and is now 20. back to
quote their country which isn't even
really their country anymore in fact I
came to the U.S legally when I was five
and legally or illegally my upbringing
my schooling my acculturization was in
the United States it had I been brought
here by my parents illegally at age five
to say when I was 20 in the middle of
college you've got to go back to
Argentina
would be extraordinarily inhumane
um and that is something that most
Americans agree with and yet we are
unable to make progress on that we've
talked about why there are political
factions at play and on and on and on
lastly
really lastly
these bussing stunts will probably have
unintended consequences and what I mean
by that is you send migrants to States
and sometimes they're not even told
until they arrive that this is happening
so it puts an additional strain on local
resources and it arguably exacerbates
difficult situations that the migrants
find themselves in okay so you're
irresponsibly and short-sightedly to get
headlines doing something which will
actually make the problem worse that
you're trying to solve because if the
migrants were able to stay or go to a
place that was actually prepared and
resourced to receive them
it would have a dramatically lower
impact on those communities nobody's
saying there is no impact when people
arrive in a community but by
deliberately choosing to willy-nilly at
10 pm bus folks to a place that isn't
even expecting them you're actually just
making the problem worse so this is what
Texas spent Christmas doing and
meanwhile look at what else is going on
again
Texas is having a power emergency
and a power plant failure and what
they're busy doing is sending migrants
in buses to Kamala Harris's house think
of it totally predictable Newsweek
reports Greg Abbott faces Texas Grid
Emergency
as power plant failed power plants fail
Texas governor Greg Abbott is facing a
Grid Emergency this holiday weekend do
it's like a repeat article but you know
you look at the date uh it is Christmas
Day 2022.
an Arctic blast is causing failures at
power plants in the state it's happening
again the U.S department of energy on
Friday declared an emergency in Texas
quote due to a shortage of electric
energy a shortage of facilities for the
generation of electric energy and other
causes
the Department's emergency order allows
Texas grid operators to pollute more
than allowed in an effort to boost
electricity generation amid threatening
cold temperatures this means Texas power
plants can burn dirtier fuel oil instead
of natural gas to generate power through
Christmas morning extra pollution folks
served alongside Santa
the electric reliability Council of
Texas known as ercot which serves 90
percent of the customers in the state
requested the emergency order exceed the
usual Federal air quality restrictions
on Friday so I just want to remind
people who maybe don't remember or
missed or weren't paying attention when
this previously happened Texas because
it is a Bastion of freedom and strength
and alpha male energy and
Liberty and what words am I forgetting
here Freedom patriotism all that stuff
they have decided to essentially
compartmentalize their electrical grid
so that when there is a shortage due to
extremely cold temperatures or extremely
hot temperatures or for whatever reason
when there is a shortage of electrical
power they are not able to just draw
from neighboring grids and utilities the
way almost all if not all of the rest of
the United States is able to do now
Texas did this because they're a big boy
they're so strong you're such a big boy
Texas and yet it fails almost every year
it seems like and as a result of the
failure
they end up polluting even more because
they get exemptions to how much
pollution they can pump into the
atmosphere because after all it's an
emergency an emergency they cost so
predictable in that it's happening again
secondly Texas spent Christmas sending
migrants to Kamala Harris's house on
buses instead of dealing with this to
the extent that they'd even be able to
deal with it so I feel for the people of
Texas I I do this is an absolutely
horrible thing FEMA is going to end up
likely footing a big part of the bill
again in order to help people and it's
not really accurate to call this a
natural disaster what I mean by that is
yes it is a weather event that is the
Catalyst for this happening yet again
but they decided to organize their
electrical grid like this they have had
years of time to try to reorganize their
electrical grid and to actually connect
to neighboring grids and they don't want
to do it and Greg Abbott is at the top
of the list of horrible people he's you
know wasting money shipping immigrants
to the vice president's house while this
is going on in Texas so this was
predictable we know the solutions we
know the political reasons why Texas has
chosen to do this and as fortunately
many states are moving forward number of
electric vehicles purchased as a
percentage of new cars is going up uh
solar capacity being installed is
increasing retrofits of homes to totally
electric heat pump systems which can be
powered by the sun solar we're seeing
all these advancements in so many states
Texas is saying we have an emergency we
caused for which we now want to be
allowed to pump extra pollution into the
atmosphere it's quite literally what's
taking place it's disgusting Abbott's
disgusting we know what the solution is
they don't want to do it Texans are
increasingly sick of it but they really
don't seem willing to get rid of Greg
Abbott for it I mean they had an option
right when it was Abbott versus Beto
O'Rourke
we knew which of the two supported
changing this urcot Fiasco Beto and we
know which of the two preferred to
defend the status quo Greg Abbott well
they got Abbott and it's happening again
and I feel bad for the people of Texas
and also it might be time to wake up and
ask for something different and vote for
something different well it's going to
be a few years now before they have that
opportunity we'll see where this goes
we'll see how long it lasts remember
subscribe to the YouTube channel at
youtube.com the davidpackman show we are
pushing pushing pushing
like a boulder up a mountain towards two
million YouTube subscribers help get us
one closer
one of our sponsors today is ginger
armor the daily moisturizing mineral
sunscreen that's good for you and the
planet I've talked before about why I
only use mineral sunscreen instead of
chemical sunscreen I want a physical
barrier rather than chemicals absorbed
by the skin Ginger armor is an everyday
sunscreen moisturizer lip balm combo
that goes on lightweight unseen and
unscented perfect for all skin types
with powerful SPF 50 plus protection
rubs on invisibly in seconds no smell
feels good after shaving to stay
moisturized all day and the super
portable design is really good on the go
and it's made with 21 simple Earth
friendly ingredients from plants and
minerals unlike the chemical sunscreens
which can irritate skin worsen certain
conditions sting eyes Ginger armor is my
go-to for daily skin protection and
moisturizing even in Winter I know
you'll love it too it's also more
affordable than other mineral sunscreens
and it is a small business supporting
the David packman show go to
gingerarmor.com and use code Pacman for
15 off the link is below the David
Pacman show is a community supported
program you can support the program by
signing up at joinpakman.com you can use
the coupon code please no more Trump
please no more Trump please no more
Trump you know it Obama yeah to get a
discount you'll get the daily bonus show
commercial free audio and video streams
of the show and all of that great stuff
at joinpakman.com will the Republican
who invented his entire backstory
including his religion education and
work history is now admitting that he
did it but he says listen none of it was
a crime I didn't commit any crime and I
plan to be a member of the U.S House of
Representatives we're talking of course
about George Santos the New York Post
scored an interview with Santos and they
call it liar representative elect George
Santos admits fabricating key details of
his bio I am not a criminal he said
this controversy will not deter me from
having good legislative success I will
be effective I will be good he says
uh my sins here are embellishing my
resume I'm sorry he confessed he never
worked directly for Goldman Sachs and
Citigroup which he claimed to have done
saying it was a quote poor choice of
words that he worked for link Bridge
which did business with those companies
all right a little bit different he says
he stated it poorly
um he admitted he never actually
graduated from any college even though
he said I graduated from Baruch College
in 2010. I didn't graduate from any
institution of Higher Learning I'm
embarrassed and sorry for having
embellished my resume I own up to that
we do stupid things in life it's not
really embellishing to say I graduated
from a college I didn't graduate from
it's a lie it's a lie now on the issue
of being Jewish
sent the article says Santos was also
accused of lying about his family
history saying on his campaign website
his mother was Jewish and his
grandparents escaped the Nazis during
World War II remember no evidence exists
to back that up
Santos now says he's quote clearly
Catholic but claimed his grandmother
told stories about being Jewish and
later converting to Catholicism Santo
said I never claimed to be Jewish I said
I was Jew hyphen ish
[Laughter]
oh boy he argues technically none of
this is a crime that's what he's going
with
I'm not a criminal not here not abroad
in any jurisdiction in the world have I
ever committed any crimes right to get
down to the nitty-gritty I'm not a fraud
I like that the knit and gritty not the
nitty-gritty to get down to the knit
and the gritty beautiful I'm not a
Criminal Who defrauded the entire
country and made up this fictitional
character in rampur it is fictitional
and fictitious and it is a fiction
the knit and gritty of the fictitional
character is really coming to light
Congress I've been around a long time I
mean a lot of people know me they know
who I am they've done business dealings
with me I'm not gonna make excuses for
this but he kind of is a lot of people
overstate in their resumes or
um twist a little bit or ingrangiate
themselves oh my God ingrangiate dear
God if he said ingratiate it would not
make sense but in Grand it's all this
guy doesn't know what's going on now I'm
actually learning much more about this
so psychological explanations for this
not from me but for mental health
experts about why people do this why do
people do this one possibility they just
have a tendency towards pathological
lying it's almost like a reflex they
have a it's a compulsion it's a
compulsion to just lie often for no
apparent reason I've told the story of
someone I knew when I was in high school
and they said my glasses are 500 this
was a very long time ago nobody had 500
just prescription glasses my glasses
were 500 because they're special I don't
even care about your glasses why are you
lying about that it doesn't make any
sense I don't care one way or the other
right all right it's a compulsion they
can't control it and often it comes with
a lack of remorse or a lack of feeling
of guilt when you do it which is sort of
what we're seeing here
um another possibility
is that it's a need for attention and
validation and so it it's not a
compulsion to lie it's this desire to be
validated by people to be seen as good
to be seen as smart and all these
different things and it can also be just
as simple as it was calculated because
he thought it would help him win he he
realized his actual record wasn't very
good uh and so he made it up because he
thought it would help him win which by
the way it appears to have helped he
should resign uh he's not going to
here's a really funny clip by the way
where Kevin McCarthy touts we have so
many Jewish people joining us and he
mentions George Santos it's great but I
really want to talk about
who's the makeup of this new majority
you heard from some of all already
you know with Max Miller in Ohio George
Santos in New York and you had David
kustoff from Tennessee get reelected
he introduced him yeah do you realize we
have the largest Republican Jewish
caucus more than 24 years very very very
exciting of course for the Republican
party so Santos should resign you'd be
fired from any job for doing this and
his argument that what he did wasn't a
crime is very very shaky there's
actually a longer interview that Santos
did it's a total softball
I don't want to play the whole thing for
you so we're going through it we're
going to pull out the most interesting
clips and we'll look at them tomorrow
well folks another tragic accident where
an individual who just happened to be
critical of Russian President Vladimir
Putin has very sadly
and very accidentally
fall into his death out of a hotel
window
it's almost like this is an epidemic in
Russia by mere coincidence people who
criticize Vladimir Putin fall out of
Windows sometimes in an act of taking
their own life as it is reported so
here's what we have and yes it is
another one of these stories it's really
December 27 2022 today this isn't a
repeat of the story like this from two
months ago or six months ago or whatever
Russian meat magnate this is the Sausage
King of Russia apparently I'm not even
exaggerating that Russian meat magnate
who criticized Putin's War dies after a
hotel fall
a Russian sausage magnate who briefly
criticized Russia's invasion of Ukraine
as died after falling from the third
floor window of a luxury hotel in India
Pavel antov was a member of Putin's
United Russia party and a
multi-millionaire having founded one of
the country's largest sausage makers he
was reportedly on a trip to celebrate
his upcoming 66th birthday when he was
found lying in a pool of blood outside
the hotel Psy International and rayagada
in the southern state of odisha an
unnamed police official told India's
NDTV news outlet they suspect he took
his own life because he was depressed
about the death of his friend who was
found dead at the same Hotel
hmm
Vladimir bidenov was found unconscious
in his hotel room on Thursday surrounded
by empty wine bottles antof was the
founder of Vladimir's standard a major
meat producer had an income of just
under 230 million dollars a year
in July posted a story on his WhatsApp
criticizing Russia's missile attacks on
Kiev as terrorism
he was referring to reports of a girl
that was pulled from Rubble after a
house was shelled shortly afterward he
apologized for the post and said it was
posted by someone else someone got into
his WhatsApp and sent a message he said
he was a supporter of the president and
my country's Patriot and shared the
goals of the invention The Invasion
um
the Russia Consul General in Calcutta
said there was no foul play so listen
was there foul play or not I don't know
but it's very strange I mean even that
story
he was at the same hotel where another
Russian died and he was so depressed of
that by that
that he took his own life it's very
strange and of course this endlessly
expanded Wiki article 2022 Russian
businessmen mystery deaths you might
remember in January we covered the death
of Leonard Shulman uh we later covered
there's so many of these I don't
remember all of the ones that we covered
more uh I believe we covered the Pavel
chelnikov death
um maybe also the Nikolai mashagi so
anyway you can look at all of these and
each is very very strange suffered a
stroke fell out of a hotel window a
hospital window all these different
things it's very very suspicious and I
know many of you will email me and you
will say David what do you mean
suspicious these people are obviously
being murdered
I I understand remember the whole point
here is no one's really supposed to
believe the story that's told like you
and I we see oh it's been reported that
they tripped on a remote in their hotel
room and fell out the window onto six
knives David that's not believable
that's the point okay I can't say all of
these are murders but some of them are
obviously murders okay the point is that
the explanations not be believable
because it's how you communicate they'll
kill you that's the entire point and so
it's not who thinks we're going to
believe these stories it's that's the
whole point they tell unbelievable
stories and here is yet another
suspicious one put it on the list of
suspicious will we ever know which ones
are what they are said to be and which
ones are the murders uh we may not we
may not but it is happening again
a judge has thrown Kerry Lake's lawsuit
over the Arizona gubernatorial election
into the trash where it belongs this is
great news and it is the right thing
judge tosses Carrie Lake's election
Challenge and Arizona governor's race
this happened on Christmas Eve a perfect
day to usher in putting this in the
trash a judge on Saturday dismissed
Kerry Lake's election challenge remember
what happened in Arizona very
complicated okay pay really close
attention to what happened in Arizona
more people voted for Katie Hobbs
so she gets to be the governor
that's what happened in Arizona okay the
judge dismissed it
saying Lake failed to prove her case
Maricopa County Judge Peter Thompson who
oversaw the two-day trial ruled that
Lake's legal team never offered clear
and convincing evidence showing the
election was rigged against her of
course he didn't there is no such
evidence
because it wasn't rigged Lake can appeal
the case before Katie Hobbs is sworn in
on January 2nd because of the tight
timetable the case may move swiftly to
the Arizona Supreme Court
Thompson noted real problems did affect
the election but election workers tried
their best and performed their role with
Integrity not perfectly as no system on
Earth is perfect but more than
sufficient to comply with the law and
conduct a valid election
okay here is her statement after
predicting endless victories she issued
this statement by the way if you're
watching
she stands like Trump now she's doing
that thing where she hinges forward at
the waist and it looks like it kind of
defies gravity
she's even standing like Trump it's
bizarre here she's calling this a win I
guess I'm just gonna make a quick
statement I am so incredibly proud of
our amazing attorneys I genuinely don't
know how people stand like that not that
put this amazing case together historic
case we proved without a shadow of a
doubt that there's malicious intent that
caused disruption so great it changed
the results of the election they did not
prove that they absolutely did not prove
that incredibly proud of a bulk rhyme by
the way had she proven that the judge
would have made a different decision
Olson who let up this legal team we
provided expert testimony we provided
experts the other side brought in
activists to try to save face they
admitted that they've known about these
ballot problems they're ballot problems
now they're trying to say that it's been
going on for three elections our
elections are a mess in this country all
right so anyway I guess she's saying
it's a moral victory some kind I don't
really know she also tweeted about this
quote my election case provided the
world with evidence
there was no evidence presented that
proves there was no proof our elections
are run outside of the law
that is not true
this judge did not rule in our favor
that's accurate okay however for the
sake of restoring faith and honesty in
our elections I will appeal this ruling
now I just want to remind you the level
of confusion around this entire thing
Kerry Lake said part of her evidence
was that people weren't allowed to vote
because they arrived after the polls
closed understand part of her evidence
is the polls were closed people show up
they're told we're closed that's
evidence it was rigged listen to this
this is truly amazing we have serious
problems with the way our elections are
run let me just read from some
affidavits of people who were taking
part in election day voting which was
now even remember affidavits are not
evidence they can be introduced as
evidence and evaluated like testimony
but doesn't even matter a massive number
of Republicans and independents who
showed up this man says at seven o'clock
a marshall announced that voting time
was over to the line outside of the
building with over a hundred voters
still standing in line okay now those
voters in line do get to vote but listen
carefully to what she says four or five
voters arrived immediately thereafter
and were very upset one voter came to
the side door to speak to a supervisor
so understand
four to five voters arrived after the
polls closed what happens when the polls
close is they say okay you sir or ma'am
are the last person in line you get to
vote
now no one else gets to get in line
every election is run this way and part
of her evidence is an affidavit that
four or five people showed up after the
poll closure announcement was made and
were upset they weren't allowed to vote
the polls were closed these are the
rules in every state so the correct
decision by the judge she's not going to
be the governor the person who got more
votes is going to get to be the governor
we'll have all of these clips on our
Instagram which you can find at
davidpackman show
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com joinpakman.com
failed former president Donald Trump
gave an interview to oan's channel Ryan
which should be a very very friendly and
positive interview she brought up nfts
AKA Trump's recent grift of selling nft
digital trading cards sorry I can't even
do it with Steve Bannon said is not good
that Trump should not be doing it that
whoever came up with the idea should be
fired she brings it up to him and Trump
basically says he thought the nfts were
cute
um this should have gone well and it did
not go very well let's take a listen to
this I'm asking you as as Donald Trump
the money man I mean you have invested
your life in tangible assets and so the
question is are you looking at nfts as
this kind of this new world of
cryptocurrency that is Sir is the new
world for the physical asset guy Trump
who did Real Estate now digital trading
cards is this the future of money
sure or is it just you're playing with
it
I viewed it differently I didn't view it
as investment I viewed it as I thought
they were cute I mean
oh God the former president thought the
nfts were this channel this is not an
investment okay but this is definitely
definitely not an investment it's just
cute for 99 you're getting these these
visions that are very beautiful and
interesting I think yes me wearing a
spacesuit for 99 bucks it's so it's just
cute and I viewed it that way much more
so than as an nft yeah but nft as you
know was very hot two or three years ago
nft is hot it cooled down you know it's
a category that happens it cooled down
so when they announce it's nft everyone
said what's he doing that for that's so
cold it was it was the reaction of many
that's true and uh I did it and I guess
it was one of the most successful maybe
the most successful but it was certainly
in terms of speed the whole thing was
sold out almost immediately
oh
this imagine if we had said in 2016
in the next six years Donald Trump will
win a Republican primary
defeat Hillary Clinton in a general
election
uh do all the insane stuff he did for
the four years
then lose to Joe Biden in 2020. claim
that he won wage a two-year War during
which he grifts tens of millions from
his followers to supposedly overturn the
results support a bunch of candidates
who lose in 2022 and then sell nft
digital trading cards and appear on oan
to say that they're cute
nobody would have believed that
absolutely nobody would have believed in
fact I can't think of a single person
who would have taken that bet and uh it
is really really something else to see I
agree in a sense with Steve Bannon that
the entire Trading Card thing is
completely humiliating but the truth is
Trump does humiliating things all the
time and so I don't know that it's
uniquely humiliating it'll be
interesting to see if it where what the
next thing is and the the hypothesis
that is increasingly forming is Trump
may be realizing that this 2024 run is
not going to go well
and if and when Trump starts to believe
that he may end up having to bail before
the first primaries as some have have
suggested may happen he is going to go
into grift mode which is what is the
most amount of money I can pull out of
this before I quietly go away and say
that's the end of my political career
and then this starts to make sense which
is what is just on this side of the law
that I can use to pick up a few extra
million
um before I just kind of quietly go away
and if you look at it in that sort of
framework with that idea then the nft
thing makes a lot of sense so even Trump
not really making sense in trying to
explain why he did the nft thing there's
nothing cute about them uh but that's
the explanation that he's giving at this
point in time Donald Trump uh issued a
Christmas message that was not
heartwarming in fact it was a scary
meltdown in which he is obviously
terrified terrified terrified of getting
himself indicted
here is Donald Trump's post to truth
Central
on Christmas and it is not exactly
a message riddled with the imagery we
might expect of reindeer and
um gingerbread I don't know what people
do on Christmas exactly you know I do
Jewish Christmas which is I get Indian
food or Chinese food and that's exactly
what I did but it doesn't seem this is
the Christmas imagery Trump said quote
Merry Christmas to everyone including
the radical left marxists of which there
are almost none that are trying to
destroy our Capital C country
the Federal Bureau of Investigation that
is illegally coercing and paying social
and lame stream media to push for a
mentally disabled Democrat over the
capital B brilliant Capital C
Clairvoyant Trump calling himself
Clairvoyant and USA loving Donald J
Trump
and of course the department of
Injustice which appointed a special
quote prosecutor end quote who together
with his wife and family hates quote
Trump end quote more than any other
person on Earth
love to all Trump says in all caps Obama
this is a man
deathly terrified
of getting indicted now later in the
show we're going to talk about the
suggestion that Trump would be best
served pleading Insanity at a
forthcoming trial hypothetical
forthcoming trial and again even if
there are charges it doesn't mean
there's going to be a trial uh this is a
guy who's very very scared and of course
we all know if and when Trump is
indicted he's going to say it's
politically biased and it's bogus and
it's nonsense and it's the radical left
marxists and all these different things
and why didn't they invite Obama indict
Obama why didn't they indict George H.W
bush for uh putting his uh documents in
a Chinese Laundry slash restaurant which
he didn't do and what about Obama's sock
draw as he likes to say he means drawer
um we know that's what he's going to say
but we know that he's genuinely
terrified of that indictment and even if
he thinks that jail time prison time is
unlikely as I do I think it is not going
to happen just it's not going to happen
even though Jamie Raskin now is saying
Trump will end up behind bars we'll talk
about that tomorrow I don't think it's
going to happen
Trump is scared and he doesn't want to
be indicted and he is likely being
advised by lawyers based on the reports
we have about their strategizing that he
is going to get indicted maybe by the
southern district of New York maybe by
the doj federally maybe in Georgia maybe
in all three maybe in two of the three
and he's terrified and he's coming
unglued and that's exactly what we are
seeing we are going to later in the week
dig into some of the other aspects of
this but later on in today's show we
will talk about Insanity defenses in
general which is actually a really
interesting topic on Lawrence tribe's
recent explanation of why that's Trump's
best bet we will take a quick break make
sure you have liked the show on
Facebook's
Zuckerberg's Facebooks at facebook.com
slash davidpackman show
if you value what we do at the David
packman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show following
up on all the of holiday weekend news
failed former president Donald Trump did
an interview so humiliating that even
his friend Wayne Allyn root couldn't
save him Wayne Allen root has been a
guest on this program many times I
encourage you to check out my
conversations with Wayne and you will
probably learn a lot about the type of
person that he is politically he was
interviewed uh sorry he interviewed
Donald Trump over the weekend and we're
gonna just look at some of it and it's
it's all pretty nauseating to be
perfectly Frank huge fan and president
Trump big fan sir I welcome you to
America's top 10 Countdown with Wayne
how are you good thanks Wayne it's great
being with you it's always great being
with you we have we've done some good
work together
we have you know you know I'm on your
team by the way the explosive platform
Rumble was able to deliver
27 000 views for this interview geez oh
boy 110 forever for life and that's my
ball game when I'm loyal I'm loyal and
that's it I never go back we need you
back as president and my opening
commentary which you haven't even heard
yet but I'm sure you'll get a chance to
see a copy of the show my opening
commentary they're gonna send them a
copy of it not the original they're
going to send them a copy was for this
Christmas I want everyone to appreciate
the great gift of President Donald J
Trump because he is our Braveheart he is
our William Wallace if you remember Mel
Gibson's movie Braveheart it's you
fighting against the Deep State well of
course I remember that movie when and by
the way Mel Gibson was treated totally
unfairly by that Jewish cop completely
unfairly Gibson's was right to ask are
you a Jew and uh listen wait sorry what
you see swamp and you're the only thing
between them and all of us being serfs
and slaves so we appreciate you I
appreciate you and I I pray to God
you're back again in 24.
well that's really nice and the Rhinos
too you know the rhinos are really bad
in a lot of ways they're worse than the
Democrats today you know where the
Democrats are coming from but these
rhinos that we have and guys like Mitch
McConnell is so bad like this Omnibus
Bill it's not even it's not even
believable they're gonna pass it
horrible it's uh just an incredible
thing it's uh how he gets away with this
stuff
go ahead I I know you come by the way
the the talking over each other is the
entire interview on the Omni bus bill I
saw your comments today his name is
terrible how can Republicans vote for
this why would Republicans vote for this
because Mitch McConnell raises money and
he gives it to Republican Senators and
they go out and vote very simply he's
not a leader he just raises money and he
gives it you know he pays gives him a
lot of money and it's amazing you know
that they can get that by because they
needed 10 Senators 10 or 12 and he gets
the 10 or 12 including himself to a
horrible Bill do you know on the border
security we get nothing and yet we're
giving four or five countries border
security for almost 500 million dollars
so they're allowed to have border
security and we're not it's not even
it's not even possible what they're
doing now remember
nobody on the left is saying we can't
have a border or border security there's
just I there's no one on the left is
saying that the point is can we fix
immigration deal with DACA actually
determine what we think we're solving
with a wall realize it won't actually
work and put in place solutions that
make sense the these are straw man
arguments on immigration
you want to get it done before the
Republican Congress comes in
this America's top 10 Countdown show so
I come up with the top ten right and you
just covered quite a few of them in
other words I said here's a bill border
security the Middle East countries but
none to ours and hisability gives
another 45 billion to Ukraine but their
Invasion but what about our border
Invasion if title 42 gets lifted what's
going to happen to America now let's
talk about title 42.
title 42 was used by Trump
to more quickly send migrants back to
their home countries okay now the
justification was we have
a unique and explosive Public Health
Emergency covet
Trump was simultaneously
downplaying the severity of the pandemic
while saying it is so historically bad
that we need to use title 42 to turn
migrants around and do expedited
deportations
are how wait it's both not super serious
but so serious we need to use something
in a way that it hasn't been used for a
really really long time because it is
such an emergency it was pure politics
that's all it was
well right now it's doing better that we
thought in the courts the courts are
sort of holding it up because uh you
know the judges
is this our country you know it gets
beyond the legal it gets like it's
Common Sense most of this stuff and uh
it'll certainly be a horrible thing and
right now it's extended to pass the
weekend but you know I was the one that
put it in it was my eyes all right so
Trump both taking credit for criticize
so immigration is a complete and total
mess let's skip ahead to another section
just to give you a little bit of the
other flavor here
yeah no I get it listen I think you're
as loyal as anyone to the Jewish people
in the history of the White House
oh right into it huh nobody's been
better for the Jews than you Don nobody
and I understand your anger and I
understand your questioning why the heck
you're not getting the Jewish vote being
loyal back to you I get it I'm Jewish
and I get it so we've explained it
before
Republicans and their pro-israel view
the way they Define it mostly appeals to
Evangelical Christians not to Jewish
Americans who overwhelmingly vote for
Democrats because on issues Jewish
Americans overwhelmingly line up with
Democrats how many times do we have to
explain this
Jewish vote in 2016 I got 25 of the
Jewish vote and I didn't do it for votes
I did it because it was the right thing
to do then I did Golan Heights which is
a big deal they're trying to get it for
60 years I got it done in 15 minutes I
did Golan Heights which is unbelievably
important but more importantly I did the
embassy I did Jerusalem remember the
embassy what he means is moving the U.S
embassy from Tel Aviv to Jerusalem that
only appeals to right-wing Americans
that's who that appeals to
um
Progressive Jews Like Me recognize
that you can't just unilaterally say
we're putting the embassy in Jerusalem
because it goes right at the heart of
much of the israeli-palestinian conflict
and the sovereignty of Jerusalem and
whether Jerusalem in an eventual
two-state solution which may never come
whether Jerusalem will or won't be the
international capital of Israel over a
hypothetical Palestinian State there's a
reason why
moving the embassy to Jerusalem didn't
make Progressive Jews which is most of
us come scrambling to vote for Trump but
he either doesn't get it or he doesn't
want to accept it becoming the capital
right they're all great and then I did
know and then I did the Iran nuclear
deal and terminated it which is was
probably the most valuable thing I did
if you want because they wanted they
want to terminate Israel so I did the
Iran nuclear deal and then a guy calls
me up who I know who's been very good to
me big strong guy he was crying over it
he was on Tucker Carlson the other day a
couple of months ago saying Trump is
great and he wanted to have dinner
because I think he needed help because
he needs help but I think he needed help
yeah yeah and all of a sudden they say
oh I'm having dinner with him and he's
in anti-semite now how am I supposed to
know he's an answer if he is an
anti-semite he didn't express that to me
by the way but if he is how was I
supposed to be aware of the major Global
story about Kanye that lasted two weeks
on every news Outlet
okay no no we've got to have
the Jews should be more loyal to me
Wayne like you yeah no I get it listen
Obama sat in the Pew of an anti-semite
for 20 years giving lectures at his
church Reverend Wright and nobody ever
said a word about it the media liberals
no one you have one dinner with a
stranger and the whole world's against
you all right so anyway I won't do this
the entire thing is 19 minutes long I
think we've had enough of it but a
friendly interview and Trump ends up
with the Jews should be more loyal to me
the Jews should be more loyal to me for
that thing I did where I moved the the
cap of the embassy unbelievable stuff
even Wayne Allen root can't save Trump
all right let's get to a legal opinion
Lawrence tribe Harvard law professor
thinks Trump should be working up an
insanity defense at a hypothetical trial
we're going to talk about the
difficulties of pleading Insanity
Business Insider report Trump's legal
team better be able to get him to plead
Insanity at trial Harvard law professor
says a Harvard law professor suggested
that Trump's legal team should get him
to plead in entity if he does go on
trial in a tweet Sunday the professor
Lawrence tribe an expert on
constitutional law commented on Trump's
video message to the house select
committee on January 6 2021 if this is
the defense that Trump's forthcoming
trial I don't envy the lawyers who agree
to represent him tribe tweeted they'd
better be psychiatrists expert at
reflexive projection and capable of
getting their client to pre plead
Insanity now we're going to look at
Trump's statement to the January 6
committee tomorrow in more detail but
Trump attacks the committee members as
being bad people he says there was no
evidence he is just a wacky wacky wacky
guy now let's talk about an insanity
defense
number one it's important to remember
that an insanity plea is not a get out
of jail free card it's a defense that
wants to mitigate the punishment for a
crime by arguing the defendant was not
in control of their actions due to
mental illness the defendant didn't
understand the consequences of their
decisions due to mental illness which
means that even if you success succeed
at defending someone on the basis of
insanity you can still be found guilty
and face punishment like being confined
to a mental health facility for example
now I don't actually think any of that's
going to happen with Trump tomorrow
we'll have Jamie raskin's recent
comments what he believes is going to
happen to Trump that but that's a
difficulty or something to understand I
would say about an insanity defense one
of the biggest challenges in pleading
insanity is burden of proof because in
order to successfully argue the defense
of insanity the defendant must present
evidence that they were suffering from a
mental illness at the time of the crime
that that cause them to lack the
capacity to understand that their
actions were wrong or illegal or
whatever the case may be that is often
very difficult to do because the
defendant needs to provide detailed
information about their mental state and
the symptoms they were experiencing they
bring in medical experts and it is a
it's difficult to meet that burden of
proof particularly if Donald Trump is
otherwise quote functioning although we
would argue he wasn't really functioning
he wasn't really working but functioning
as president of the United States
there's also the stigma that surrounds
mental illness because there are many
people who view mental illness as a
weakness or a character flaw rather than
a medical condition so even in a case
where the defense actually can meet that
burden of proof
there are still
jurors as a general people who may end
up on the jury
which might not be easily convinced that
what they were seeing were the out of
control actions of someone suffering
from mental illness rather than just
somebody who broke the law so Insanity
defense is an uphill battle
if it's Trump I think it's a
particularly uphill battle because of
the other circumstances I mentioned in
addition to the difficulty of getting a
jury
that would be neutral enough about
Trump's actions that they would really
give the insanity consideration
um the fair consideration that it would
ideally get in front of a jury so I
think it's a big uphill battle and we
may talk more about that uh in the
future but that's Lauren's tribe's idea
we have a voicemail number that number
is
2192 David P
uh here is a caller who is Bravely
engaged in fighting the war on Christmas
which doesn't exist okay let's take a
listen
David sir this is James hope you had a
good Hanukkah thank you
um I wanted to talk to you about uh the
issue of the war on Christmas Yes
um
with maybe one exception I've never
actually heard of anyone get offended
uh when someone says Merry Christmas but
I can't tell you how many uh right
Wingers I've heard get offended by happy
holidays um
I think it's time that that the
progressives really really call the
Republicans out on their on their you
know wokeness and their
um they're policing speech someone says
happy holidays and they go why aren't
you saying Merry Christmas to me goodbye
happy holidays I mean they really are
snowflakes it's happy holidays
triggers them that much
um
but yeah hardly anyone I've I've met
actually gets offended by Merry
Christmas
anyway I hope you have a good rest of
your holiday season and uh
hope to hear from you soon yeah so
listen
um I I tweeted the other day and some
people got so mad at me I I was serious
when I tweeted it but it's not like some
big thing when people say happy holidays
to me around this time of year I go
happy holidays yeah and if they say
Merry Christmas I say oh happy Hanukkah
it's just like it's not a big deal I'm
not doing it aggressively it's just if
they wish me Merry Christmas because
that's what they celebrate I wish them
happy Hanukkah because that's what I
celebrate it's not a big deal no one has
ever gotten upset no one has ever gotten
offended it's it's kind of a joke but I
I do do that do that I'm not offended
nobody's offended it's really not a big
deal the thing that really does seem to
offend people
is these right Wingers when they are
told happy holidays they believe they
are being told happy holidays because
some woke Marxist leftists Obama yeah
like Obama or whoever right
has pressured uh a worker at Best Buy
to forego Merry Christmas and instead to
say happy holidays so it is true I don't
get wish me Happy Kwanzaa I don't care
wish me whatever you want and then I'll
respond however I want no one's offended
we're having conversations it's fine
okay
but the people who get offended are the
ones wished happy holidays when they
believe they should be wished Merry
Christmas and it's pathetic we have a
great bonus show for you today
this it's unbelievable that this even
happened
at least 27 people are dead in Buffalo
New York because of a snowstorm
okay we're going to talk about the
horrifying situation in Buffalo
Adidas much less seriously Adidas is
scrambling to sell over 500 million
dollars worth of Yeezys after cutting
ties with Kanye West
uh where what are they going to do with
them where are they going to end up it's
an interesting place by the way where
sometimes uh clothing and shoes end up
when they are no longer sold on the
retail Market we'll talk about that and
a new poll finds that Arizona now
independent Senator Kirsten Cinema would
get crushed if she ran as an independent
in 2024 which was supposedly one of the
considerations in her moving from uh
Democrat to Independent all of those
stories and so much more all on today's
bonus show how do you get the bonus show
you sign up at joinpakman.com oh the
bonus show where you want to make money
yes everybody else that makes money to
fund themselves is bad well depends how
you're making that money Alex that's the
truth we're offering nothing other than
a good time with the award-winning bonus
show you can sign up at joinpakman.com
you can use the coupon code please no
more Trump and you have to say it that
way when you enter it please no more
Trump we'll see you on the bonus show in
mere moments
thanks a lot for watching Today's Show I
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors Ginger armor is
the daily moisturizing mineral sunscreen
perfect for any skin type chemical
sunscreens can cause health issues
including skin irritation and stinging
eyes but with ginger armors ingredients
from plants and minerals and it being
scent free and rubbing on invisibly in
seconds it's the best get 15 off with
code Pacman using the link below